project android applications wants
say design for mobility
always keep in mind the scenario of
use of mumbai and device
applications it contains are
applications used in motion in
which the user does not have your complete
attention where your app is yours
app is not the center of his thoughts
the use of mobile applications e
often inserted in a context driven by
multitasking where the user could
interrupt the flow several times
natural that you imagined the app
because maybe he's getting one
phone call I just received a text message in
more clearly there are limits
physical then reduced control screens
limited battery consumption
connection to the network not always
optimal is constant is another thing
to consider that the download e
data upload is not always free
for the user
let's see now some of the operations that
require more resources in terms of
battery consumption that have a high
impact on the battery then use
of the network
in the event of poor network coverage
mobile consumption is very high
using bluetooth gps to make itself
when the switch-off is avoided
screen
using the camera indoors
of the oil application reactivate the screen from
a standby state
these are all high-level operations
impact on the battery that
toast to the battery
let's see some of the gestures now
most common is generally accepted by the
user's mental model from
use
the simplest in applications
really the simple touch on the
release that launches the functionality of
basis for the given element then there is the
long wait too long
release that allows you to enter
selection mode often selection
of one or more items on a list
the opening of a context is the menu that
allows you to make reports on i
selected items and then we have the swipe
which often serves to navigate between
views of the same hierarchical level e
it is also useful for showing contents in
overflow the classic and the case of
dl of navigation ros the double touch
which is often used for
enlarge the element if expected e
we also used for the
selection of texts are double touch
two touches two touches in rapid succession
then we have double touch and drag that
serves to enlarge or reduce the zoom
taking as a reference point
just that of double touch
the google maps application and is a
some of the best to protest this
this is what we are doing next
that long pressure with drag
often this gesture is used
to rearrange items or inside
of a list promoting items in a
determined containers then remain the
last two the last two gestures which
are the pilots in the cross then touch with
credit moving outwards top
agreed inward movement
the first is useful to enlarge the
general content of the view that
second useful to make the
always the main content of the view
that we are looking at one of the
most common mistakes is to create
confusion of its own in the
management of
of gestures supported by
application to avoid the problems of the
generally the strategy of making sure that
the app immediately responds one
determined gesture and above all not
conflicts must be created between two or more
gestures one of the main challenges in the
release an android application of
quality is definitely a guarantee
good experience on many versions
of the operating system in circulation e
on the multitude of devices on the market
in the image we see the historian of the
releases of the operating system from cupcake
to kit kat
is a distribution that you can find
a graph that you can find on the site
android developer and it is constantly
updated then when you face the
design of a new application
you can update yourself by going to these from
food here we have as we were saying how
we said the release history from
operating system
and here we can see the distribution
of various screen sizes
of the various diversities
so on the one hand we have one
still quite distribution
consisting of old versions
on the other hand the absolute necessity seen
the very high level of the competition
to create a unique user experience
almost magical with ours
the good news is that from android 4.0
therefore and pil is of 14 all the producers
are required to include themes with themes
android or in their distribution
this is a good thing because
starting from here it was possible
define a plus to the municipality showed
unifying the lines
general guidance and creating an experience
consistent uniform to android users
android in general communion
defined provides
an action bar for actions
fast is the hierarchical navigation on
various features of the app 1 rig and shawn
drover in which to insert the navigation
of the different sections of the app is a
container and as android programmers
probably a ministers who towards
thirteen could make us life a lot
easier
the problem is that at the moment
register this video distribution is
the one you see here is also there
the need for
having to provide user support with
old versions of the operating system
reto meyer in google and youtube
and 13 suggested creating the best
best possible experience
possible for all users
especially those who use the latter
devices on the market because
actually those are yours
target considering that hundreds of
thousands of new devices come
activated every day and that come
released new very useful features
from the android team to the new ones
distributions
so if the advice comes from meier it is
one of those to be followed by mine and by
create a unique and flowing experience
pleasant to anyone with an eye on
regarding clearly to whom to device of
last generation
obviously all this requires a
correct support for most
of the different screens more to a diet
however of continuous continue to
keep a version of your app
for old platforms thanks
to support many epic exhibitions
more information at this link is
really all for now live I invite you to
follow the next videos where
we will deepen the individual or ipad defined
by google guidelines to understand
exactly which scenarios to fold them here
find my references for any
type of suggestion or question is the
next appointment where we will talk
of the application structure as
implement good navigation
Hello